Our reading today comes from the 14th Psalm. It's also in the handout.
The fool says in his heart, there is no God. They are corrupt. They do abominable deeds. There is none who does good.
The Lord looks down from heaven on the children of men to see if there are any who understand, who seek after God.
They have all turned aside. Together they have become corrupt. There is none who does good, not even one.
Have they no knowledge? All the evil doers who eat up my people as they eat bread and do not call upon the Lord?
There they are in great terror, for God is with the generation of the righteous.
You would shame the plans of the poor, but the Lord is his refuge. Oh, that salvation for Israel would come out of Zion.
And the Lord restores the fortunes of his people. Let Jacob rejoice. Let Israel be glad.
The word of the Lord.
Thanks be to God.
Let's pray together.
Lord, yes, you are sufficient and your word is sufficient as well.
So Lord, I pray that as we come to your word now that you would supply what we need both for today, but also for eternity.
In Jesus' name we pray. Amen.
I wonder what comes to mind when you think of a fool.
And you should not be looking at one another at the moment.
Maybe think about a silly TV personality like Michael Scott from The Office or I don't know, Mr. Bean, something like that.
There are certainly kind of real life examples when you think of, I know you hear about celebrities, rock stars, that kind of thing,
who really hit it big and live it up while the money lasts and then they lose everything.
I read not too long ago about a well-known singer and musician from the 70s who was then living in a van in California.
He was homeless, so went from having everything to having very little because of the foolish way he had chosen to live.
Well, we can't be sure what would come to David's mind when it comes to a foolish person,
but we can have a pretty good idea of the sort of person he would have thought about,
particularly when it came to who he encountered in 1 Samuel 25.
There was a man called Nabal and there's no connection in this psalm,
you know how some of the psalms have a specific connection to a specific account.
We don't have that here.
Nonetheless, you can't help but wonder if this guy came to mind.
This was back when David had been anointed as king, but he was still on the run from King Saul.
He and his men had made their way through an area where Nabal had a bunch of land where his sheep were there.
Nabal was a very wealthy man and were told that he had thousands of sheep and goats
and he had lots of shepherds that worked under him to look after those sheep and those goats.
It was a feast day and you can read about the kind of ample supplies that he had.
He was able to really live it up.
This is a guy who seemed to have everything.
David thought, well, we've treated their shepherds really well.
It's a feast day when people would normally have their neighbors around
and would kind of celebrate together and share in their food and celebration.
Surely on a day like today, they will help us out and supply a bit of what we need.
David sent a few of his men to go and speak to Nabal.
Nabal's response was not a good response.
Nabal basically said, David who? Who does he think he is?
He insulted David's men.
He said that he wasn't going to give them a thing and kind of sent them away empty-handed.
When word got back to David, David was furious and he would later say that his response wasn't the best.
He basically said, all right, I just sent a few last time.
Now I'm going to gather an entire army, which he did.
He gathered the whole army and he was basically going to come and wipe Nabal out.
He and the army were on the way, but Abigail, Nabal's wife, found out about what Nabal had done.
She was mortified by her husband's behavior.
Now some of you wives can identify with Abigail here.
So she said, I can't believe he said that and she heard that David and his army were on the way.
So she made her way out with a bunch of supplies, the kind of supplies they needed.
The supplies got there first, so this gift came from Nabal's abundance because of Abigail giving it.
And then Abigail came and she just apologized profusely.
And she said she was so sorry for what had happened.
And then she said, you know, my husband, Nabal, has lived up to his name because his name means fool.
That's what his name meant.
So my husband is living up to his name.
He is a fool.
So David actually accepts the apology.
He owns up to the fact that he was taking vengeance in his own hands.
So he was glad that she stopped him that day because it wasn't the right thing.
He should have left that to the Lord.
But when she came back to Nabal, he was none the wiser.
He was this guy who wouldn't welcome the king was at home feasting like a king.
Like he was enjoying all his resources on this feast day and he was drunk as well.
And he was just wasted.
And so she came to him and she thought, well now's not the time to speak to him.
I'm going to speak to him in the morning.
So when the morning came and he'd sobered up, she came to him and told him what had happened.
That David and his army had almost wiped everybody out.
And we're told what happened to him.
He says that his heart seized up within him.
And he died 10 days later.
It says the Lord struck Nabal and he died.
This is a cautionary, vivid tale that is before us in the Old Testament.
So King Nabal, so to speak, defied the Lord anointed.
And he decided to rule over his own little kingdom.
But his power and the pleasures that came from it were enjoyable for a short time.
But they were short lived.
He'd made a short-sighted decision.
He seemed to have it all.
But in the end, Nabal lived up to his name.
He proved to be a fool.
So years later, David sits down and he writes a Psalm.
And the first word he writes in Psalm 14 is Nabal.
That's the word here when it says the fool says in his heart.
The first word is Nabal says in his heart.
So Nabal, in 1 Samuel 25, was not the first fool nor was he the last.
So as we look at the Psalm, we would all do well to ask whether or not any of these Nabal-like characteristics are true of us.
Well, this is our last Psalm we're going to be looking at in this kind of introduction to the book of Psalms.
And this series we've been going through in the summer.
Well, we started in Psalm 1 and we saw there before us the way of the ungodly and the way of the righteous.
And here we're kind of returning to that in some ways, but instead of it's talking about it as the way of the righteous and the way of the ungodly,
it talks about the way of the righteous and the way of the fool.
So the fool is the one who's in the place of the ungodly here, the ungodly fool.
So we're just going to look at that together.
So we'll look at the way of the fool and the three characteristics there and then the generation of the righteous or the way of the righteous.
And we'll look at three characteristics there too.
So first of all, the way of the fool.
To just return back to Psalm 1, you might remember it's about the blessed man.
Blessed is the man. That's where the book of Psalms begin.
And you have this blessed individual who's the personification really of a life that is truly blessed.
And it points us to Jesus and the eternal spiritual blessings that we can know in him as the blessed man.
Well Psalm 14 kind of begins in the opposite way.
Instead of it beginning blessed is the man, it begins the fool.
So a foolish individual is put before us as the kind of personification of the kind of life we want to turn away from.
It's the opposite of a life of blessing.
So what are these three things that it tells us about the fool?
Well the first thing is that the fool is atheistic.
The fool is atheistic. So let's read it.
The fool says in his heart, there is no God.
So that doesn't mean that someone who would say they're an atheist is not an intelligent person.
Nevertheless, knowledge and wisdom are not the same thing.
You can be an academic, you can be a best-selling author and still be a fool.
But what's being addressed here isn't so much what we might call intellectual atheism.
It's certainly included in that when the fool says there is no God,
but it's not just intellectual atheism that's addressing here.
It's what we might call practical atheism.
So whether or not the fool believes that God exists theoretically, they live as though God did not exist.
That's the point of what's being said here.
So a few things that might lead us to that conclusion that that's what's being addressed here.
I mean one, notice where the fool says there is no God.
The fool says in his heart there is no God.
So in Hebrew thought, the heart includes the intellect, certainly,
but it also includes the emotions.
It includes the will.
So this is the whole person here.
This is a decisive rejection of God coming from our mind, our will, our emotions.
So it's not just somebody contemplating, do I think there's a God or not?
It's somebody saying, I'm rejecting God.
Another reason why we see this is more like practical atheism here is because
actually the words there is, when it says there is no God, are not there in the original Hebrew.
What it literally says is the fool says in his heart, no God.
Now it's a perfectly fine translation and it does mean there is no God.
But removing those two words can give us some insight into the sense of what's being said here.
So the fool says in his heart, no God.
It's like a sign on the door, like a no entry sign.
It's like Nabal saying, David, David who?
He is not welcome here.
Entry is denied.
So the fool refuses to give God his rightful place in their heart.
They say, no God for me.
Thank you very much.
It's like in Romans 1 where the apostle Paul talks about how in nature alone
there is enough evidence to point us to the reality of God's existence.
Nevertheless, people resist him, not merely on intellectual grounds, but on moral grounds.
He says in Romans 1.18 how people suppress the truth in unrighteousness.
Because what is to be known about God is plain.
God's shown it to them.
And he goes on to say, how those who claim to be wise become fools
when they suppress the truth of the knowledge of God, that inner compass that points to God when they suppress that.
They become fools.
The author and agnostic Aldous Huxley once spoke very honestly about his mixed motivations for his unbelief.
He made it clear it wasn't just purely on intellectual grounds that he didn't believe in God from a place of certainty.
Let me read you a quote.
It's kind of a long quote, but it's interesting to hear what he says.
He said, I had motives for not wanting the world to have a meaning
and consequently assumed that it had none and was able without any difficulty to find satisfying reasons for this assumption.
The philosopher who finds no meaning in the world is not concerned exclusively with a problem in pure metaphysics.
He is also concerned to prove that there is no valid reason why he personally should not do as he wants to do.
For myself, as no doubt for most of my friends, the philosophy of meaninglessness was essentially an instrument of liberation from a certain system of morality.
We objected to the morality because it interfered with our sexual freedom.
So did you catch that?
He didn't want to live under the constraints of the kind of morality that would come if God existed, if Scripture were true.
And so because he didn't want to live under those constraints, he then looked for reasons that matched up with where he was already at in terms of his worldview and what he desired in life.
So whether or not you believe in the existence of God, this kind of practical atheism here,
following after what our hearts want and then adjusting our theology accordingly, is something that we can all be guilty of.
In fact, every time we sin, we are living as practical atheists.
We're living as though God didn't exist.
Or whether or not we didn't want God to be in that particular area of our life.
So the question we need to ask ourselves as we see this is, is the God who reigns over all welcome in my life?
Is he welcome in every area of my life?
Or do I deny him access?
And then this inward kind of posture of defiance against God.
Like I don't want God in my life or I don't want God in this area of my life.
That posture of defiance has lived out in practice.
So it talks about how the fool says no God, but it also speaks repeatedly about no good, no good.
So no God leads to no good.
And there's a word that's used to describe this and it is corruption.
So twice it speaks about the corruption of our state and our deeds that flow from that.
So verse one again, but the second half says they are corrupt.
They do abominable deeds. There is none who does good.
Go to verse three.
They have all turned to sides. Together they have become corrupt.
There was none who does good, not even one.
So the fool is not only atheistic, but also corrupt.
The word corrupt means spoiled, rotten, ruined.
So maybe you've been in a situation where you go and you go to the fridge, get some milk out,
and you pour that glass of milk and you take a big swig of it only to discover that it's soured.
You know, just get this repulsive taste in your mouth. You've got to spit it out.
I've certainly been in that position before. It's an awful feeling.
And this is what it's saying about the fool.
So the way of the fool is like that. It is off.
And it can be seen in what they do.
You see that kind of sourness there, but also in what they fail to do.
It all comes back to this corruption.
It's like what Paul says in Romans 8.
He speaks about our flesh as being that corrupt part of us.
And he says, those who are in the flesh cannot please God.
In other words, this corruption has moved into every part of life.
So we might...
Let's move over to this for a second.
We might see where it says there's none who does good and say,
well, sure, I can think of good that's done by awful people.
Like even the worst of us do good.
And maybe just think about the sour milk for a second.
So it would be technically true to say,
well, there's parts of that sour milk, if you break down it to its various components,
that are still good, you know.
But are you going to drink that glass or not?
No, because the sourness has affected the whole.
There's a corruption that has affected the whole of it.
So this is what Scripture says about our state apart from Christ.
We are corrupt.
The corruption has affected the whole.
This is why in Isaiah, I think it's 64,
speaks about our righteousness as being as filthy rags.
This is our righteousness apart from the grace of God in Christ.
There's a corruption that spills into everything.
And so our corrupt actions are coming from a heart of corruption.
So this is not to, I mean, there's an element of the idea of,
say, pushing God out of our lives or out of society,
how that can lead to corruption.
So that's there.
But actually what's being said in this Psalm seems to be flowing in the opposite direction.
It's because they are corrupt that they do these abominable deeds.
So corrupt actions flow from corrupt hearts.
This is just exactly what Jesus taught in places like Mark chapter 7.
So we might look at this.
Okay, so there's this pollution that's flowing downstream.
And so we know that the source of this pollution must be upstream.
You got this evil heart and evil actions are flowing from it.
So is this a special category of person that that applies to?
Which leads to the third thing we see here.
The fool is not just atheistic and corrupt.
The foolishness spoken of here is universal as well.
Universal.
So verse two, David gives this mental image of God peering out of heaven
and looking down on humanity.
The Lord looks down from heaven on the children of man to see if there are any who understand,
or any who seek after God.
It's a bit like the account of the flood in Genesis.
Remember God looks out over mankind and he sees that corruption has affected all of it.
So what does God find this time as he surveys humanity, the children of man?
Well, verse three, once again they have all, notice the word all turned aside,
together they have become corrupt.
There is, note the word, none who does good,
not even one to just drive the point home a bit further.
So the corruption of the human condition is universal.
The way of the fool is the way that we all follow, apart from God's gracious intervention.
So in Psalm 14, you can kind of see a contrast between the world and the people of God
and what's being said, but when you look at the New Testament, how it interprets Psalm 14,
you go to Romans chapter three, Paul quotes Psalm 14 verbatim.
If you feel like I've seen this in the New Testament before, it's because it's there.
Paul quotes this saying, there's none righteous, there's none who does good.
He uses this as, in a way that points to the fact that whether you're Jew or Gentile,
all of us have sinned against God.
So put simply, naturally we are all sinners.
And our sin problem isn't just about what we do, it goes deeper than that.
It comes from who we are apart from Christ.
It comes from corrupt hearts that want to be in control rather than welcome God and His reign in our lives.
So without God's gracious intervention, none of us would seek after Him.
We cannot do good unless He graciously cures the corruption that has affected us at the very core.
And if we continue down that path, notice what it says in verse five.
It says, there they are in great terror.
So there's great terror to come for those who continue down the way of the fool.
It doesn't end well.
It's a feast like a king, but in the end that will be short-lived, that pleasure.
Because God is with the generation of the righteous.
Alright, so that's where we want to be.
The way of the fool, the generation of the righteous.
It doesn't end well, short-lived for the fool.
So let's see then the generation of the righteous.
So how do we move from that category?
It's not good news at all to the category of the generation of the righteous.
Well, as we've already seen in some of the other Psalms,
the difference between the righteous person and the unrighteous,
or here the righteous and the fool,
is not that one has sinned and the other has it.
So God looks over all of humanity and says, all have sinned.
So the righteous person can't be the person who's gotten it right.
And it can't be the person either who's kind of really kind of turned around
and made themselves better or anything like that.
It's not that they've just changed their ways and started doing right.
Now the difference between the righteous and the unrighteous,
or the righteous and the fool,
is that the righteous has this right relationship with God.
The difference is found in their relationship to God.
Unlike those who follow the way of the short-sighted fool,
the generation of the righteous will see they welcome the Lord,
they know the Lord's presence dwelling in their life,
and they know the hope that he gives.
So let's see this together.
All right, so the generation of the righteous.
Unlike the fool, they welcome the Lord.
So they call upon the Lord.
We're told in verse 4, at the end,
that the fools do not call upon the name of the Lord.
So the opposite, therefore, must be true about the righteous.
The fool turns aside or away from the Lord,
but the righteous turn from their sin
and call out to the Lord.
I may have mentioned this before,
but one of my favorite shows in the early 90s was Rescue 911.
Any of you watch that?
I'm dating myself here.
If you've not seen it,
people are dating themselves by agreeing with me,
because you've seen this.
If you've not seen it, go on YouTube.
So the basic idea of it is they take actual 911 calls
and they dramatize them.
There's some really amazing ones that are there.
And William Shatner is kind of talking you through
what's going on.
But one of my absolute favorites is this teenage boy
who was looking after his younger sibling
and somehow managed to get his tongue stuck in the freezer.
And so this teenage boy has this predicament.
Now, I am stuck in the freezer.
My tongue is stuck there.
I don't want anybody to know about my stupidity here
sticking my tongue in the freezer.
But I need help.
So he's calling out to his sibling for help.
And eventually the sibling gets the phone to him
and he's got to call out for help.
And if you want to hear the best 911 call of all time,
somebody with their tongue stuck in it, it's great.
But here's the point.
He had to own up to his stupidity
in order to get the actual help that he needed.
Like you don't get one without the other.
Calling meant owning up.
All right, so this is what we have here.
The righteous are the ones who own up.
They've made the call.
They own up to their sinfulness and call out to God for salvation.
They lay hold of the promise of Scripture.
Whoever shall call upon the name of the Lord shall be saved.
But don't shut him out.
They invite him in.
And this invitation to call upon the Lord is open to everyone.
The call is to come in repentance to the Lord
and to confess him as your Savior and King.
When we do that, he forgives and he saves.
This is where our life with him begins.
But it also characterizes our ongoing life with him.
His people are a people of prayer.
So by grace we become those who seek after God
to use the language of Psalm 14.
We want to know him more.
We live a life of daily repentance
and trusting in him.
This is the life the Lord wants to give us in Christ.
Hebrews 11 verse 6 describes people of faith in this way.
It says,
He who comes to God must believe that he is
and that he is the rewarder of those who diligently seek him.
People who put their trust in God seek after him in prayer.
But also, so they don't shut God out.
They call him in.
And then they dwell in his presence.
Verse 5 again,
They are in great terror, that's the fools.
For God is with the generation of the righteous.
So when we call upon the Lord, he not only forgives us,
he makes his dwelling within us by his spirit.
And when it says that God is with us,
it doesn't just convey his presence in our lives.
It also conveys his protection as well.
Throughout the Old Testament, for example,
you see God's people being attacked by foreign armies.
But when the Lord assures them that they're going to be okay,
he assures them by saying, I am with you.
That's the promise that's put before the Lord's people.
The Lord's presence is with his people.
And that is what is their protection.
So here in Psalm 14,
the generation of the righteous are opposed and oppressed by the world.
But they have nothing to fear.
Why? Because God is with them.
So when Jesus said, go to all the world
and make disciples of all nations, that's a daunting task.
But then what does he end with? The same promise.
And behold, I am with you always.
Let's see verse 6.
You would shame the plans of the poor,
but the Lord is his refuge.
So the dwelling in the presence of the Lord.
Well, who's the poor here?
Well, the poor, that's the righteous.
That's the generation of the righteous are described as the poor here.
So the poor are those who are in a place of weakness and vulnerability.
And they are being mocked by the appearance of their weakness and vulnerability.
But they're not bothered because their strength is not found in themselves.
They are not sufficient in and of themselves.
Their sufficiency is of God.
So their strength is found in the Lord.
So they're poor, yes, they're weak, yes.
But they have a strong refuge in the Lord himself.
They know the Lord dwelling with them.
It's like Joseph.
You know, you're reading Genesis, Joseph going through so much years and years of estrangement
and imprisonment and false accusation.
And the list goes on, but it repeatedly says,
but the Lord was with him.
The Lord was with him.
And then because the Lord was with him, the Lord brought him to a place
where things were turned around for the good and for the salvation of many.
Now, this doesn't mean we will not face difficulties,
but it does mean that whatever we face, we can face them knowing that the Lord is with us,
that he is for us, and he will bring us into all the good that he has promised.
The righteous, those who have called upon the Lord can say,
the Lord is with me and he is good and he is powerful.
Lastly, they also hope in his salvation, the generation of the righteous.
So let's read that last verse again.
Oh, that salvation for Israel would come out of Zion.
When the Lord restores the fortunes of his people, let Jacob rejoice, let Israel be glad.
So the psalmist here is living in the hope of the future when everything will be made right,
and all that has been lost will be restored.
So yes, the generation of the righteous is described as poor, as people who are lacking something,
and they're being shamed for their trust in the Lord.
But it ends with saying, we may appear to be poor, but our fortunes are on the way.
They will be restored.
When you get to verse 7, you see that though they may be poor and oppressed now,
the Lord will appear and bring their fortunes with him.
So this kind of restoration of what has been lost comes through Jesus.
All right, so this cry is here.
Oh, that salvation for Israel would come out of Zion.
But from our perspective, looking back on Jesus, we can say, salvation did come out of Zion.
Jesus did come bringing deliverance from death and sin.
He brought deliverance and salvation through his own death and resurrection,
through his ascension to his heavenly throne.
And we can rejoice now and we can rejoice in the hope of all that is to come because of Christ
and the blessings that are ours in him.
So if you are in Christ, no matter what is taken from you in the world,
you have an inheritance in him that nothing can take away.
The fool might want to hold on to everything this life can offer.
If we know Christ, we know that what we have in him is far greater than anything in this world.
Nothing can take that away.
So this is why in Ephesians 2, Paul speaks in this way.
He speaks about God's riches, God being rich in mercy.
Because of the great love with which he loved us, even when we were dead in our trespasses,
made us alive together with Christ for by grace you have been saved
and raised us up with him and seated us with him in the heavenly places in Christ Jesus.
Why? Why did he do that for us?
So that the fortunes might be restored.
Here's what he says in Ephesians 2, 7.
So that in the coming ages, he might show the immeasurable riches of his grace
in kindness towards us in Christ Jesus.
So yes, fools trade in superior lasting goods for temporary fleeting pleasures of the moment.
We see that just in terms of what we see in the world around us.
I mean, fools like, you know, go for the short term pleasure and leave out the longer term good.
We see that just in this life, but it's also true eternally as well.
The fool says that no God for me in this life.
But they forsake their eternal good in doing that.
There's nothing compared to knowing Christ.
So, yeah, Jim Elliott, the missionary martyr, had it right when he said,
he is no fool who gives what he cannot keep to gain what he cannot lose.
What we have in Christ is far greater.
So how shall we respond to this?
Well, heed the warning.
Don't go the way of Nabal.
Our first response looking at this Psalm should be to repent,
to say that is the way that I have gone and I'm turning away from that and I'm turning to Christ.
So unlike Nabal, unlike the fool, welcome Christ as your King.
And he will come and he will forgive and he will make his dwelling in you.
And when he makes his dwelling within us by his spirit,
he helps us to live in the assurance that we have a glorious future that awaits when we will feast with our true King forevermore.
Lord, I pray that you would help us to be a people who heed the warning that we would not be like Nabal.
Lord, that we would not reject our true King.
Lord, I pray that we would welcome Christ into our lives and into every area of our lives.
Lord, as we think about opening up every area of our lives,
Lord, we would admit that there are areas that we struggle where there is sin.
But Lord, we thank you that grace and mercy is abundant in Jesus.
So Lord, I pray that you'd help us to be a people who turn from our sin and repentance.
Welcome Jesus and the forgiveness and cleansing he brings.
Lord, I pray that you'd help us to be a people who gladly know your presence and your help as we look forward to all the good that is to come.
In Jesus' name, amen.